because I don't care is the answer to
your question the reason I'm able to
deal with very tough challenges it's
because I don't have my self-worth
wrapped up in my businesses God forbid I
make the wrong decision I will lose
money who cares God forbid I make the
series of many bad decisions in a row I
will lose my business who cares and then
I play the reverse what if I did
everything right and became the most
successful businessman in the history of
the world but the next day after I
achieved that my mother passed away
would I be happy the answer is no and so
I keep my life incredibly simple
detached from my professional career I
have passion for my professional career
I love my work I love this game I love
this but it is not in my soul it is my
Play and so it's very easy for me to
make challenging decisions